[Music]
chuck i got another one for you
all right it's called friction
oh my goodness yes friction
now friction usually when people talk
about friction it's bad
all right bring out the wd-40 it's
squeaking
it's friction fresh and burn
friction burn right right right but let
me tell you
without friction life as we know it
would not be possible
hmm friction is your friend
see i have lots of missing
skin on my knees to differ
so uh so friction i mean just think
about it if you just sort of
put your elbow on the table right and
you just rest it there
yes and then you want to listen to me if
there was no friction
you would just slide
there'd be nothing keeping your elbow
there that's why i stopped wearing silk
shirts
[Laughter]
so so and let's say you wanted to drive
your car
you need the friction between your tires
and the road
so that you will move forward if there
were
zero friction between your car and the
road
the wheels would just spin and nothing
would happen
okay you would go nowhere you wouldn't
be able to
start the car to move the car slow down
the car
stop the car or even steer the car
all of that requires friction
to walk to walk
you put a foot down there is friction
there you press back
and you your next foot moves forward in
advance of it
that required friction this is why on
slippery
ice where there is no friction you can't
walk you can't run and you say oh
and you say this is bad put me back on
regular ground what you're really
pleading for is give me some friction
right you don't say that because
friction has a bad name
and what do you do when it's cold out
and you're not wearing gloves what do
you do
hands get hot i just realized it's cold
in my house
okay so you do that
okay friction is your friend
so so we'll do a whole other thing on
friction becoming heat that's a whole
other explainer
that needs its own time for that but a
friction can help get you warm
all right so the only thing that really
does not use friction
is rockets all
other transportation requires friction
bicycles trains okay uh
uh planes in order to take off okay oh
my goodness that's right
all of this requires friction
to take pictures the planes needed to
take off ah
so with a rocket however by the way it's
why
rockets work in space where there's no
air there's no
nothing rubbing against anything else it
sends material out the back
and it recoils forward right so all
rockets that are accelerating are losing
mass
in order to do it in a recoil whereas
you don't have to lose mass to do it you
just have to press against the earth
right well newton told us for every
action is an equal and opposite reaction
so if you are stand still and you start
moving forward
actually something has to start moving
backwards
and it's communicated that way through
friction so what happens
you move forward with a certain momentum
what are you pushing against
the ground the ground the ground has to
move backwards
and it does so the entire earth
is responding to the fact that you moved
in one direction
okay oh man could we all get together
every human being just in one group and
start running in one direction
will we speed up the earth yes or slow
it down depending on which direction and
it has to be due east or due west
correct you do eastwood yes so if
so if everyone lined up okay and started
running due east okay
so that will sort of spin which way we
turn we're turning
this way so you have to run and run due
west
and if everybody does that with their
scurrying feet you will
speed up the rotation of the earth what
that's the that is the response of the
earth to
you propelling yourself forward
by way of friction connecting you to the
earth itself
it's true with cars it's true with
everything i once did a calculation
and i said let's get our most powerful
rocket engines bench mount them
at the equator where you have sort of
maximum torque on the earth and can we
use that to either speed up or slow down
the earth
and i did the math on that and it's
hopeless
okay it's like a gnat flying full speed
into the side of an elephant
and believing the elephant even took
notice
okay very confident that
very confident it's a very confident
that
in fact it's less than that so but but
take that dumbo what i'm saying is the
momentum that
we all gave each other by putting
ourselves into motion you can write down
that number
momentum is your mass times your
velocity that you gave yourself
okay earth's rotation
increase or decrease will have changed
by exactly that same amount of momentum
so that they both cancel because you
started out both not moving relative to
each other
so if one thing starts moving the other
thing has to recoil the other way
so that they balance out that's physics
101.
so if you go forward earth goes
backwards by the exact same
total momentum but earth has so much
mass
relative to all the mass of the humans
that your momentum which is
mass times velocity that's the only
quantity that has to be the same
all right so all we humans run forward
and add up all our mass and get our
velocities add it all up and we've got
this hunkering earth
with this really large mass and it gets
a teeny litty bitty velocity
to balance us out so if you don't notice
it but
you can calculate what that effect is
and it is real it is real
wow excellent and it's friction it's
it's all friction so
i just want you to think of friction as
as a good thing
it's more good than bad one thing
friction does is it slows down things
that were put into motion
and aristotle not really understanding
friction
[ __ ] got most of his physics wrong
by the way he's not a champion
he's no hero in physics and astrophysics
thank god he have philosophy
philosophers like him uh and he did
important things but
there's stuff he could have really
checked and he didn't and so
it's it's before experimental philosophy
kicked in as opposed to thinking
philosophy and and
and so the experimental philosophers
bacon had a whole book just on
experiments that he said he conducted
but there's like a thousand experiments
in it and that's what all he'd be doing
every day
for the rest of his life so i don't
think he did them all but it's
it's a book and he collected them and so
he
and galileo they do the experiment
if you have an idea okay so because
otherwise
and no disrespect aristotle you're just
[ __ ] you're just you're just
thinking stuff up that you think should
be true
because it makes sense to you we can
so he said things in motion tend to come
to rest
okay so
[Laughter]
that's true right all right but galileo
said wait a minute
if i wax the track you know i have a
thing i roll it down the hill and it
stops like here
now i make it smoother it stops a little
farther away make it even smoother it
starts even farther away and he said
wait a minute
what would happen if there was no
friction on this track
where will it stop and he concluded
that things in motion will tend to stay
and he fed
newton's things in motion tend to stay
in motion
it's the opposite of aristotle unless
acted on by an outsider wow look at that
and so galileo was the bridge between
aristotle and newton and doing the
experiments
by waxing the track uh making it ever
more smooth reducing the friction coming
that enabled him to
establish a fundamental truth about
nature
going beyond just what your life
experience is
so look at that galileo the mr miyagi of
physics
who knew what
wax on white sauce
so i just want you to appreciate uh
friction
you know i i i will i will not i
know i still can't get my head around
liking friction
but but it is necessary without without
friction everything would just be
floating
would be gliding sliding around sliding
around you sit on a couch the couch
would just slide
back by the way you could push very
heavy things
if there's a freight train i don't care
what it weighed if it's on frictionless
tracks
let's say it's a maglev frictionless
track and you have a little a little
handle
just take it and start pulling so you
can put a force on it and
yes it's way more mass than you are so
the velocity will be small
but it'll have some velocity right so
you can just start pushing it
and this is why those strong men
competitions okay
where they pull with in the old days
they pull the train with their teeth
okay it's because trains are on steel
rolling wheels on steel tracks
which has very low friction
okay if you took it off the tracks
and let it sit there in the mud and then
have them try to tug the train
that ain't happening that's that's kind
of funny though
you could pull things that have wheels
on them because wheels have very low
friction
in the transmission of the movement of
that object to the ground
because you're not dragging it on the
ground
right but the wheel itself still needs a
little bit of friction
in order to not spin spin out that's all
that's so cool oh you know i i have to
say i
i i will never think of friction in the
same way
[Laughter]
one last thing okay one last thing
uh when astronauts re-enter the
atmosphere and they have that
you know the the burning phase you know
yes the flames and the the
all right we say oh my gosh will they
survive this is bad how good
no you need that
the astronauts coming out of orbit are
going 17 000 miles an hour and they
didn't bring
fuel to break
oh okay because all they would have to
do all they would have to we don't do
this but what they could do
is bring enough fuel while you're in
orbit at 17 000 miles an hour because
that's orbital speed
turn your ship around and fire it
backwards
right that will slow you down and you
keep doing that
until you like have zero velocity and
then you just drop
out of the sky if you drop out of the
sky you're not going to be burning up
because what's burning up is the kinetic
energy of having gone 17 000 miles an
hour in the first place
i saw a movie i think it was it was one
of these mars movies
uh one of the earlier ones that came and
went
where there's something happening on a
platform and the guy falls off the
platform
but it's a stable platform up there
above the ground
and as he falls we see him just burn up
he's like
no no the act of falling through the
atmosphere alone
is not what burns you up it's the fact
that you're going from 17 000 miles an
hour to zero
and where does all the kinetic energy go
there is
friction between you and the air
molecules passing across your surface
there's also shock waves that
communicate as you're going faster than
the speed of sound
shock waves take all this energy that
you have
and convert it into heat and then the
heat dissipates
and then you fall down out of the sky
alive
because you have special heat shields
that protect you
uh-huh there you go and before we
perfected the
the tiles that we used on the shuttle
you know what the heat shield was
astronauts
they weren't really shields a shield is
something that protection
we call them shields that's not what
they were you know what they were
they're like onion layers
of burnable material oh so they just
burned
off exactly but you had to go through
enough of them
to get to the to the crispy center
where the astronauts are where the
astronauts are so
so it turns out coming out of orbit you
need more of these layers than when you
come back from the moon
so coming back to the moon to just make
that layer thicker and then
it ablates and it heats it burns off and
goes out that takes the heat away
and eats as these layers go so it's a
very blunt effective
heat shield but it's really a shield
that dissolves away
in the heat all of that the friction the
shock waves
and that allows you to not have to take
fuel in order to
slow down using fuel because you're
basically aerobraking
sweet that's what re-entry is it's a
form of aerobraking
that is fascinating friction is your
friend that's what i'm trying to tell
you
chuck every astronaut loves friction
otherwise they can't come home
no you can't come or you need fuel to
slow down that's all i'm saying
you want to exploit to exploit what you
got and so you should say
great they're burning up their heat
shields that's a good thing
sweet all right all right i'm liking it
chuck
is your friend all right i i got a new
friend today
that makes one or makes one one one
french
chuck and his one friend i got my
boyfriend frixion
all right uh neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
you